this helped me understand the app so much better and saved me so much time of having to like
investigate all of these rpc ids uh it took about 15 minutes to set up
and that investment paid massive dividends and i got a 20k bounty because of this
best part of hacking when you can just you know critical thing right
all righty hackers we got the this weekend bug bounty segment three entries this time first one
up is from a collaboration between hack the box and hacker one uh there's a ai red teaming ctf going
on from uh september 9th to september 19th and it gives you an opportunity to try 10 different
challenges uh what do they say here over nine escalating challenges and one final boss you'll
work through ai powered apps where the goal is to override filters bypass logic and extract data you
shouldn't have access to so if you are trying to kind of cut your teeth a little bit into ai red
teaming this is a cool opportunity to work with hack the box and hackerone so check it out if you're
interested link will be in the description um next up is yes we hack one of the one of the amazing uh
sponsors that we have the podcast just wanted to let us uh have us let you know that they are going
to be at rootcon this year in uh the philippines they've got a team out there um from september 25th to
26th definitely go say hi interact with them uh if you see them around uh they'd love to to meet you and
and hang out um and then also in line with yes we hack uh they recently released their hardware
monitor dojo challenge of the month um this time we got an lfi and it's looking pretty juicy you guys
um so definitely go check that out if you're wanting to refine some of those ruby lfi related
skills all right that's all we've got for this week in bug bounty segment let's head back to the show
all right hackers here's the deal uh this week we've had a bunch of cancellations and sickness and stuff like
that so um this episode is going to be a little bit on the fly and essentially it is i was thinking to
myself what am i excited about what do i want to go yap about for 15 minutes to give them an episode
to listen to this week and um what i'm excited about is kaido and so what i'm going to cover today is a
couple new uh features and plugins that have been released in kaido um over the past couple months
that i think you should know about uh and that i use on a regular basis all right so um let's jump right
into it whether you use kaido or burp i think these are really um important features to be aware of
because they push the community forward in general right so even if you um even if you're not using
kaido maybe you should think about these features and how you can do them in burp uh or you know sort
of bring parity to the ecosystem there um so that we can all enjoy better hp proxies all right so let's
jump right into it first one um sort of and also i will add this is sort of extracted from the
presentation that i gave at defcon in in part i'm definitely not going to be able to go into as much
detail as i did there but um this is a little bit of the content of what i talked about at defcon
so if you were there sorry for the for the repeat but um for the most of you this will be newish content
okay um for those of you familiar with kaido there's this concept of httpql and httpql is
something we use inside of kaido to query different um sets of data uh throughout the the kaido ecosystem
you know sometimes we use it for search sometimes we use it for filtering um conditional things like
matching uh match and replace or um conditional intercept that sort of thing um and one of the things
i found myself doing pretty often was like oh i saw a request you know five minutes ago and i need that
request and i i'm scrolling and i can't find it so i'm just going to search for it really quick
um and one of the things that kaido does allow you to do is search for the time that a request was
created in um so i was you know sort of trying to get some workflows in place to to um figure out how to
search quickly within kaido um within a certain time frame and i built into this uh plugin called
even better this uh feature called common filters and it essentially what it does is it gives you a
list of filters i'm going to go ahead and pull it up here because i can't remember which ones um i have
but it's recent which is within the last five minutes one hour six hours 12 hours 24 hours and so
you can just kind of attach timestamps really quickly to your hdql queries and it will limit the
amount of um you know results that you get which makes the search instantaneous um and also allows
you to sort of narrow in on the exact time frame that you want so that's called common filters they
automatically update every minute so that you can get the latest um you know updated version of that
filter and they're very convenient to use so check that out if you're using um hdql and kaido
also another feature that i recently integrated into the even better plugin is uh convert workflow
command palette entries so a lot of people don't know this but um kaido has a command palette that
is uh pretty awesome in my opinion um and you can activate it by pressing ctrl k and what what the
integration with convert workflows will do is it will allow you to run um my dog is barking all right dog
has been dealt with i'm back um anyway command palette uh entries uh have the various convert
workflows that you define within kaido which is super great so you just type c and then the name of
the convert workflow that you want to do and it takes your currently selected text inside of kaido
and uh runs the convert workflow on that uh so if you're actively in replay you know where you're modifying
stuff it makes it super easy to be like okay you know you're on code this basic foreign code this super
quickly um with command palette without having to take your hands off the keyboard um if you're not
inside of replay or like an editable editor it just copies it right to your clipboard which is super
nice for getting stuff uh into the right format um so that you can use it later in inside your clipboard
um so i've been using this really often this is like probably the feature that i've integrated into
my workflow uh the the quickest with kaido you know when a new feature comes out because it just makes
sense to have these right at the tip of your fingers and using the command palette is just really nice
because it's consistent with the way that i think about oh i need to basically see foreign code so you
know ctrl k basics foreign code boom done um so definitely check those two features out those those
are in the even better plug-in um in the kaido store okay next thing i'm excited about which i've
talked about a couple times already so you know just bear with me guys is the notes plus plus plugin
is amazing and it really has changed the way that i make notes in kaido okay um and there's a couple
reasons for that but the feature that i use the most is the um windows shift n feature in notes plus plus
which you can be in replay you're doing your thing you find a gadget you find something you need to take
a note on and you just press windows shift n and it pops up in a little box that's attached to your
current open note in notes plus plus um and you can uh write whatever you want in there and uh it
there's a little box that's automatically checked that says attach current context and what it will do
is insert your note into the the note that you have in your in your plugins uh notes plus plus tab
but it will also attach the current replay tab like a beautiful graphical representation of the of the
um current note so let me go ahead and for those of you that are on um those of you that are on youtube
i'm going to go ahead and share my screen really quickly here so you can see what i'm talking about
because it is it is quite nice um here we are here it is right here so you can see you know the the
beautiful graphical representation of this specific request and you can click on it and jump right over
into this um you know a http request in replay um super clean uh very useful for making sure that you
know where all of your requests are um and i use it constantly really i kind of struggled with taking notes
before but this makes it so easy that i i actually do it now um one of the improvements that i would
like to kind of see in this area which is something we're thinking about implementing is the ability to
do voice notes and i know monkey did a uh plugin a while back um sort of that had a feature like this
but it would be really awesome if we could just press a key binding and then just say bloody bloody bloody
ba you know enter and and that would be automatically converted into into text and stored in the note for
us i think that would be the maximum uh amount of friction reduction like that would just make it super
easy um but i guess you do have to have like your microphone and stuff like that um i don't normally
hack like this with my microphone right next to my face and stuff like that so um yeah i guess i guess
there's some workshopping to do there but i think it would still be really helpful um i yeah i think
that's good for notes plus plus um definitely check it out if you're if you're you know taking notes
inside of your uh kind of environment um next up is shift agents and i've talked about shift agents i
believe once or twice before in the podcast uh but i have recently started using them and it's super helpful
okay um so what i've done is i've created a couple microagents and the one that actually has found me a
vulnerability or i guess this one's more of a gadget that i've chained into a vulnerability
uh is my domain restriction bypass uh uh microagent okay so uh for those of you that haven't heard of
shift agents let me explain what it is essentially shift agents is the ability for you to um define little
microagents within kaido okay and so you can give it like you know system prompt or whatever it's got
all the tools to like modify your current replay tab and that sort of thing um and then you you give
it tasks and it you know creates a to-do list goes through the to-do list if it finds something
interesting it creates a finding for you to alert you of what it found okay so it allows you to sort of
build your own hackbot workflows within kaido um and the one that i built like i said was a domain
restriction bypass uh um uh microagent and i i had a scenario where i was looking at an open redirect
um looking for an open redirect and i handed it off to this agent and it was able to go through my whole
workflow uh successfully you know that i would have done manually okay let's check the dots for regex let's
you know check it ends with let's check an invalid you know um uh parsing of um you know the url let's
check unicode normalization and it was actually able to find a vulnerability um via the you know at
sign at the front of the url um and and that was something that i had documented in the various you know
uh uh system prompt sections that i passed into it and then it was able to correctly identify that
and create a finding with open redirect um so that saves me time and effort right first i i give it a
stab at it right so for those of you that haven't played around with it essentially how it works is
you open up a replay tab you pop open the little um agent side window you give it uh the system prompt you
want and then you know some just in time uh instructions and then you essentially delegate
that replay tab to the ai then you know you continue doing your thing you come back you know
either it creates a finding and you see it on the side or you come back and you can review what it
did by sort of tabbing back and forth between your replay session um and seeing what exactly it did
so for me that's been working quite well i've been pleased i was pleased that it was able to
implement that it saved me time i think i've used less than seven dollars total right now um as far as
money goes you know to to fund the ai um on open router um yeah and and i've had decent success with
gemini uh that's the one i've been using currently but i've heard from you know the xbox write-ups and
stuff like that that uh gpt5 is like a big level up as far as hacking performance goes so i'm excited
to play around with that a little bit as well so um i think now is the time you know i guess without
without you know fighting it too much this industry is going to change for sure within the next year
um and has changed already you know if you're not using ai at all in your workflow you know if you're not
like at least having a gemini tab open and being like hey you know tell me about this tell me about
that um or using it to parse docs or you know attack vector id8 or do source code review um then
you're behind to be perfectly frank with you um but i think it's going to continue to progress in such
a way that if you are not integrating ai directly into your workflow to save you time
then you're going to get even further behind so i think now is a good time to start developing these
microagents you don't have to use them constantly but just realize that um developing these microagents
is not a a sunk cost because eventually uh they're going to work eventually they're going to work
amazing right um and as as you start refining your prompt over time that prompt you know can be
ported okay maybe shift agents isn't the thing you use maybe you use something else right but those
prompts can be ported into you know other ai um assisted hacking um systems okay so go ahead
and get started writing some some some system prompts and i think shift ai is a great great place
to do it okay um you can grab that in the kaido store by the time this episode is out the new
version of shift agent should be integrated to shift in the kaido plugin store so you'll grab it
play around with it write yourself a system prompt um these episodes are typically longer right
they're not these little little short episodes so the time that you would have spent listening to ctbb today
okay go ahead and and take that and build yourself at least one system prompt um in in shift agents
and uh throw it at something this week okay i think that'll be a good a good step for most of you
to start integrating ai into your actual hacking workflow all right next up is uh drop which is uh
just super awesome okay this is a plugin that i wrote in architect and actually this is probably my crown jewel as far as engineering goes uh because it's a pretty sick plugin
uh because it's a pretty sick plugin and it uh is end-to-end encrypted and it allows you to send uh
uh like various objects in kaido imagine replace roles re you know replay tabs uh http requests from hdp history
scopes filters whatever send it to your friend instantly within kaido so all you do is you grab your friends you know uh pgp public key
you drop it into into drop you drop it into drop see what i did there um you drop it into drop and then
now you just literally on any object in in kaido top right corner typically there's like a little drop
button you click that click their name and then boom it's in their kaido instance super seamless extremely
easy to set up publicly host an instance with uh full end-to-end encryption using pgp you can read the spec
and all the code is public so you can see exactly what we're running um definitely use it if you
collaborate at all with people it is extremely useful um all right that's as far as it goes for plugins
let me tell you guys about a couple more things and then we'll call it a wrap for today um
lately i have been having a lot of fun with workflows in kaido um workflows are the way for you to do sort
of quick and dirty automation um within kaido and they're gaining a lot of capability and they're going
to continue to gain a lot of capability um over the next quarter or two um one of the things that i've
been doing recently is using uh the auto session refresher functionality that i built in in in the
workflow and if you guys are interested in figuring out how to do this um you can go to kaido.rinerader.com
and i've got a lab there that i set up for the becoming a kaido power user workshop at defcon
um and there's a little lab where you can download the workflow and that sort of thing but the tldr of
the situation is you can create a passive workflow in kaido that automatically looks at for you know a
specific coast grabs a specific set of cookies or cookies or whatever and then creates an environment
variable which is like sort of a way to store data within kaido um with those actual values
and then uh and it just does that constantly anytime a request comes through hp history
then whenever you are looking to like send a request and replay and you press send and it's like oh 403
your session expired you're like shit now i gotta go create another replay tab and then no everything
gets so messy so the the right way to do it is have the session refresher automatically extract the
session and then you just create a replay placeholder with that specific environment variable that's
always updated and then you never have to worry about updating your session ever again and your
session will always be live so um very very useful piece of functionality there um the template workflow
for that is at kaido.rinerader.com under the session monitoring lab so go ahead and check that out
if you want to get your hands on it also the latest version of kaido comes with finally i convinced them
to ship it uh my top level navigation highlighter plugin now this is literally one of the most
transformational things that i've ever seen in in in hp um proxies okay um and essentially what it
does is it just uses sec fetch headers to highlight top level navigations in kaido and that is finally
shipped native with kaido which is great so just go to passive a workflow turn it on and then when you
you know do a top level navigation in your browser or an iframe level navigation you'll see that highlighted
inside of http history which makes it super easy to orient yourself within kaido if you're not using this
your life will change when you use this okay so please just give it a shot i'm begging you because
it is super helpful for orienting yourself in http history and i have literally no idea how i lived without
it like it takes forever to find any request now without this i i loaded up a raw version of kaido the
other day and i was like uh how does anybody do this in burp or in raw kaido without this on um so definitely
life-changing all right last but not least i wanted to share a little case study of how i used kaido
workflows recently um to really really enhance my hacking experience okay there's a target that i was
hacking on that instead of sending requests to a specific path they would just send it to all to
the same path and include an rpc id okay that rpc id was just a six digit alphanumeric string and it
was super annoying because you could never tell what was happening in the app um however in the js files
there was sort of a mapping it wasn't a direct mapping it was like you know a couple hundred
characters separated but they were always you know the same couple hundred characters separated
between the rpc id and the actual like name human friendly name of whatever that rpc correlated to
um so i was able to create a workflow plus match and replace rule system here that allowed me to
sub in that id um the human readable value for that directly into the http request um at send time
which allowed me to understand this app so much better without having to constantly cross correlate
these rpc ids okay so here's how i did it i created a passive workflow and what that passive
workflow is run automatically anytime request comes through http history that passive workflow would
look for a specific um uh you know regex in the in javascript files and it would extract
the rpc id to human readable path correlation okay and it would store that in a kaido environment variable
so now you've got a map of rpc id to path boom uh extracted with passive workflows then i created a
match and replace rule in kaido which um adds a query parameter uh which first you know checks the
regex uh to make sure that this request is you know the one of the requests that has the rpc id
and then it adds a query parameter to the request um so and then sorry let me let me be clear the
replacer for the match and replace was a workflow right so this is one of those sort of advanced
workflows that you can do um or advanced match and replace rules that you can do with kaido
where you match on a regex and then you your replacer is actually generated by a convert workflow
okay so um you match on the regex you extract the rpc id from that regex and inside of the convert
workflow you cross correlate that um rpc id with your all of your environment variables right and you
say okay oh i found the rpc id now i've got the corresponding path now let me go ahead and add a
query parameter to that specific request that says human readable path equals and then you know
whatever you cross-correlated it to and then i was able to look at the modified request in search
um and just kind of use that as my hp history for now um where i could see the flow of the actual
human readable versions of the hp requests um as they were coming through this helped me understand
the app so much better and saved me so much time of having to like investigate all of these rpc ids
uh took about 15 minutes to set up and that investment paid massive dividends and i got a 20k bounty because
of this and the 20k bounty was literally like an idor in the front of this app but nobody found it
because everything was so obfuscated and uh and hard to to work on so take some time invest deeply in
these um uh in these sort of ways to improve your your automation uh and you'll find some really crazy
stuff all right guys that's a wrap for today i gotta call it um yeah i know this isn't the typical episode
but i hope you guys enjoyed it and got something out of it anyway um all right we'll see you next week
peace and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end
y'all if you want more critical thinking content uh or if you want to support the show head over to
ctbb.show discord you can hop in the community there's lots of great high-level hacking discussion
happening there on top of master classes hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild if
you're a full-time hunter it's a great time trust me i'll see you there